Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
I'm just checking in on you and your cubicle.
Do you like that?
It's in the corner and you get some sun.
I like it.
It makes me feel like I'm outside.
Do you know what I mean?
Do you remember when you had [inaudible] and he just ran and he just had the
wind was in your hair.
That's what it feels like except them inside in my dream thief died.
What's going on guys?
My voice is fucked up.
And uh,
it's Wednesday night.
I just got out of the writer's room,
episode eight motherfuckers doing the table.
Read fucking Mazda with it.
Fuck to these fucking things.
Come from Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah,
it's fucking Moss.
It's fucking house.
Do you know the fuck another day?
My God.
Damn.
I get a fucking decent gate for the driveway for once.
You know,
you got to get the electrical one.
You know what's great about the electrical one is eventually it fucking breaks
and you can't get your car out of there and you got to call a taxi.
When you're paying insurance on two fucking cars,
all,
oh,
they're right there.
You just can't get to them.
Isn't technology wonderful?
It makes your life so much more simple.
Um,
you know,
you don't have to get out of a car anymore to open a gate.
You don't burn those calories.
And then those calories just sit right on your fucking heart,
right?
And then one day,
one day the gate doesn't open and you have a fucking aneurysm because you so
upset because it was supposed to make your life easier.
And it doesn't actually have a fucking theory.
Uh,
I don't have a theory.
I have a fucking idea that just popped into my head.
We should all die at like 30 of natural fucking causes.
You know,
we should just go back to living off the fucking land once,
just the whole plague just hits everybody.
We should just,
you know,
go back to being fucking cave people and live in like,
it's live in like 30 fucking Ya.
You can't go that far back would be a good place to go back to.
You know what I mean?
Well,
anybody in this era would suck because then there'd be a bunch of shit and be
like,
what does no iPads or polio vaccines,
man,
what the fuck?
This sucks.
Right?
You know?
I don't know.
It's not a theory.
It was just a fucking idea.
I mean,
and this is how Trump gives a speech,
isn't it?
Is he going down?
Is that what's happening in this fucking guy?
Just took everybody until this fucking moment.
Now I,
for the life of me,
I do not understand how this,
this is my fucking republican choice.
I got this fucking dope or this,
this fucking square headed God damn criminal.
What does Hillary Clinton have?
Like what?
52 felonies pending?
I think I saw her on the first 48 the other night
and how they're just going to just blow past all of this.
And then you got to listen to all this fucking horse shit about,
you know,
how great it is for fucking women.
Well it's only fair after all the guys that have got an office,
why don't we get the most crooked,
fucking broad we can find,
you know,
don't pick the honest one.
Um,
oh Jesus.
I'm going to grumpy fucking mood.
Um,
there's so much shit that I want to say,
but I can't say it.
I just can't fucking say it.
Uh,
cause it would be a waste to say it right here,
but I am buying my time biting you.
Or is it buying is a Joe Biden.
How to fuck these.
I know the,
how they explain this one of those expressions.
I've a,
every time I hear somebody say it in a bar,
it's like,
did they say buying or I'm biding my time
or is it just you?
Another thing that one of my relatives mispronounced and then I just started
saying it that way.
Like my fucking,
what am I?
Relatives could not say orange used to say orange.
You want an orange so you know he fucking go to school.
What color is that?
I'm like orange.
And people would look at me like,
what did you say?
Orange.
And they're going,
it's orange.
Say all right.
You know,
I didn't know.
Yeah.
People around where I live say orange.
Um,
the fuck was I talking about biting
my time is,
is that a word?
Is that something biding my time.
Well that's a pink Floyd song biding time.
Uh,
biding my time.
Can you believe there's something on Wikipedia about that?
Well,
there's people like you in the world,
Bill.
So there needs to be
biding my time was an unreleased.
Recording isn't an excuse,
isn't an expression.
The sea,
once you guys are hearing right now is how I use the fucking camera.
The computer.
I'd just ask it.
I talked to it like you can hear him well it can't hear me cause he fucking,
I'll say shit to my wife and all of a sudden,
you know,
I'll be like,
you know the fuck is your problem.
Well,
you know,
you treat me like a Douchebag,
right?
Then all of a sudden I go to my computer and on the side there's all these
advertising for Douche bags and I never looked it up binding my time instead of
biding my time.
The side in the binding one's time is a verb that according to the American
heritage dictionary means to a wait or wait for oh God.
People who are into language to that level going into the American heritage
dictionary.
Somebody fucking sat down and look that up.
It's Wikipedia.
Why wouldn't you just make it up?
This podcast,
by the way,
is brought to you by cores light.
It's cold lagers,
cold filtered,
and cold packaged.
And you know what?
When I'm pitching shit jokes all day long and a fucking writer's room,
I like to come home,
do a podcast and drink one can of fucking cores light.
You know why?
Cause it's fucking delicious.
It's perfect.
I don't want to get hammered.
It's sort of tastes like water,
but I have a nice happy feeling afterwards.
Um,
this is me not drinking is every two days.
I have one beer,
one,
you know,
nobody in the England,
whatever,
or the Europe in general would consider a fucking beer.
By the way.
Belgium is back on the fucking map.
That back on the map,
we were trying to go to Germany and Austria,
but they offered me like $30 and 50,
or maybe it was your rose.
I can't remember what.
So I dunno what the fuck I got going on over there.
Um,
I got to start trashing their sports teams so they know who the fuck I am.
And maybe they'll watch a few videos and I could maybe,
I don't know,
play whatever their version of what's funny.
Bone Yard.
Go to see funny bone.
All right,
let's get back to the fucking podcast.
Uh,
what happened today in the world?
I have no fucking idea.
I S I sat in a fucking writer's room all God Damn Day.
Um,
let's see.
Google news,
Google News.
All right.
In the U s a comprehensive up to date coverage aggregated.
Sit and spin.
Sit in spurs late night clash.
All this is about the gun shit.
Uh,
daily trail.
Asian stocks wobble ahead of somebody cares about that.
Somebody has so much fucking money that that's going to gives a fuck what's
going on with their stocks.
You know,
once we became this giant financial fucking gang bang,
it's just over alligator that snatched two year old boy at Disney world has been
killed.
How the fuck did they find it?
It didn't eat them.
There was no evidence of the kid and him.
Right.
Somebody rat them out.
Some other fucking allegate iron man.
It wasn't me.
I,
you know,
somebody was talking the an alligator probably snatched the kid was like,
Jesus Christ.
It's a fucking kid.
Thought it was a turtle.
I don't,
I don't want to get fucking suit and I'm either going to kill me.
All the animals,
they got to know her at this point that if you fucking,
if you even fuck with the human being,
we come down and we track it down.
You know,
we'd done it to alligators.
We've done it to sharks.
Who'd done it to gorillas that fucking alligator with the second he fucking saw
a shirt was just like,
that's not a turtle right?
Spit the kid out and then fuck it took off and it still wasn't enough.
We come back around like bedbug Eddie and fucking a fucking popup.
Greenwich village.
Two alligators,
not three
Bonnie,
some Irish fucking alligator.
I don't know.
I'm shitting
coast guard,
cruise.
Find Body and search for missing father,
three teens.
Oh my God.
People are out of their fucking minds.
People go out on boats.
You know what I mean?
Stay in a lake.
A lake is,
is his brutal enough?
Just cause the creepy thing.
A lake is usually so fucking cold.
It never gives up your body.
You just stay down there.
You know,
it doesn't get warm enough for the gases in your gut to fucking make you be a
fucking flow.
Duh.
You know what?
I learned that reading that book,
the Westies that when they used to make people do the Houdini is they say,
you know,
they'd kill people then they would chop them up.
They're big fucking thing was he had the yad to Yad to gut them.
You know?
Cause if you didn't,
you know,
whatever happens,
whatever happens when you die,
you know there's probiotics for the good bacteria in your gut than there's a bad
bacteria,
that bad bacteria that exists in your gut your whole fucking life sits there
waiting for you to die.
And when you die it activates.
And that's what fucking makes you decompose according to the person.
Two stools down for me at a diner one time.
All right?
Maybe I saw it on the fucking Internet.
I have no fucking idea.
I'm on my way to a slap fight or some shit.
Whatever the fuck I was going to watch,
by the way on Twitter.
I've got another good one.
Okay.
Worldstar hip hop.
You got to follow those guys.
And then there's 32nd fights.
Fucking unbelievable.
Watch the guy back a car over a woman today.
She was fucking up his car,
right?
You know,
you know a women when women fleeing,
you know,
flip out whatever the fuck you did cheated on them or whatever,
they fuck up your property because they're not going to get arrested for it
cause they have a fucking clamp.
Right?
So this fucking,
she's throwing shit at the guy and the guy's trying to drive away and she throws
like three or four fucking things at him.
I don't know what it was.
And finally she throws his last fucking thing at the guy and the guy just stops
and starts backing up towards her.
And I'm thinking he's,
he's just going to scare,
he's going to bumper,
you know what I mean?
Give it the old fucking,
you know,
a little,
you know those bumpers,
you know,
most of them made out of fucking flexible plastic figure.
Worst case scenario,
she's going to get a Joe Theismann.
This fucking guy bumped her and then just stomped on the gas and fucking backed
all the way over and continue to go and then fucking,
and that's what kills me.
I was just,
I was like,
oh my God,
I thought she was dead.
Don't she got up?
It was like a cartoon.
Like I thought that Shit only happened in a cartoon.
I would think once you go underneath a fucking car that was going as fast as
this fucking guy.
I mean you just gotta think bent the rear axle.
You got the differential right there.
She's getting the right,
they have Fred,
but the fucking differential,
forget about the tires,
how the car is hot,
all of that shit.
How it didn't drag her down the fucking street.
It's one of the most brutal things I've ever seen.
Having said that,
they're not all like that.
There's a lot of good flights on there.
I feel like watching fights like I do,
I enjoy watching.
You know,
I liked violence.
I like watching it.
I don't know why.
I like watching animals attack each other.
I like people fighting each other.
Uh,
it's enjoyable to me,
but I also like,
you know,
I like playing horseshoes.
I like that.
Uh,
what do we call,
do you call it?
Shit.
I made a reference to it.
My Life's special for these slide on the ice with that giant like obese hockey
puck or that has a handle on it.
Curling.
I liked that too.
I can watch that white dude with the Afro do the paintings on Netflix,
you know,
going to put a happy tree right over there.
Is that what you're gonna do it?
Yeah,
go ahead and do that shit.
I can watch the 700 club.
I can do a lot of shit,
but I get the end of the day.
I still enjoy the violence.
Um,
all right.
Las Vegas awarded an NHL Franchise.
Oh Fuck Jesus Christ.
What are they thinking?
What are they trying to become?
The NBA that you know,
I'll tell you right now,
if you think the fucking NBA is fixed now wait to the v Vegas gets a fucking
teeth.
Kevin Durant's signing with Golden State Warriors.
Warriors would be mutually beneficial to Ho Warrior fans.
Steven Tyler says the Aerosmith train won't keep a rolling after next tour is
the end near Jesus Christ.
That'd be one his was more intense.
Mocks calls Tesla's solar city deal.
No brainer.
Investors disagree.
Two,
how has this,
this Tesla Guy,
man,
this guy is just,
he's fucking with,
he's fucking with some old money.
So the guy who makes the Tesla car,
by the way,
you guys like Jag was,
I liked their entry level one.
The fucking,
you get to top of the line sports model one,
you get it in that fucking British racing green.
I just wish you could get it in a stick.
Every cunt out has got a fucking,
it's basically there are three series,
you know,
which is really,
if you give a fuck,
should be the highest series that you buy because some do.
She's going to come in and side swipe you if you're lucky.
Maybe they leave a note in there and let's see what this guy's doing.
Elon Musk inhabits a world of declarative super loud at ups.
Well,
whatever world that is,
I don't know what any of those words mean.
The claritive super low additives,
he lives in that world.
Well,
no one or you figured out to make an electric cargo that fucking fast.
He lives in a world of declarative super lattice.
Jesus Christ as a whole and the fucking group of people I've never met.
How many are in?
They're shitting all over the place and fucking walking into guerrilla and
closures
on a conference call with investors early Wednesday.
Tesla CEO
call this company is two point $8 billion offer for a solar city.
A No brainer,
uh,
that it's legally and morally correct.
A zero doubt move that we should have done sooner.
I agree with all of this.
I don't know how much it should cost.
So what's more must trumpet trumpeted that the deal could help propel Tessa
toward the world's first trillion dollar company as the solution to the earth's
climate change problem,
Jason,
to Trump,
right?
This analysis aren't so sure.
Well,
who were the fucking analysis getting paid by the big oil companies at a steep
drop and Tesla's stock down 10% in Wednesday's trading whacking 3 billion off
its lofty $32 billion market Cap Confirms Investors Skepticism.
Fuck you.
You just don't want to see him do it.
Why can't the government gives some money the way they did the banks
fucking solar city,
man,
you make weed legal,
Bri,
you grow it under solar panels every morning.
Everybody,
you know there's like a continental breakfast,
right?
You get eggs from chickens,
sits still have their beaks and they're not on roids like Mark McGuire,
right?
They got that little fucking waffle flippy thing.
You pour it in and then you turn it over.
You know,
somebody sent me something today,
we're actually some scientist,
which I'm sure he's underground,
right?
He has no corporate money behind them.
Described humanity the way every great comic I've ever seen as starting with
fucking Bill Hicks that basically said that human beings are a plague.
I remember one time reading a Joe Rogan blog and he was fucking said he was
flying over the u s and he was looking down and just seeing how beautiful the
country was.
And he was just looking at all the city.
So she went through and how dirty and filthy where he said,
we're like a fungus.
You know what I mean?
And I,
if you could interview fungus or whatever,
uh,
virus out there that could kill us.
If you could talk to them,
you know,
they don't think they're bad people.
You know,
they don't have that perspective because it just hanging around with other
viruses where people have the same virus.
You know what I mean?
Like,
if you could interview a chicken and ask him what a thanks to human beings.
I mean,
you wouldn't want to see,
remember the last episode of Seinfeld when everybody came back and talked about
what selfish pieces of shit.
Elaine,
Jerry,
a fucking Diane.
Whenever the fuck then a Kramer.
Oh,
what's the other guy's name?
Eddie.
Um,
okay.
Anyways,
they were talking about pieces of shit.
They were,
you have chickens,
dolphins,
anybody,
poisonous snakes,
tigers,
all of them.
If they could just sit down and talk about it,
say yeah,
they wouldn't like us.
You know what I mean?
And they keep,
then you know what?
They'd go back to all the Qur'an.
They'd go out to the fucking Bible,
the Torah,
all our religious books and just be like,
yeah,
they read this thing and then they think it's okay to fucking do a bunch of shit
to us.
Cause some fat guy named Buddha said it was okay.
You know,
what do you guys think?
Like the right population numbers should be,
you know,
and how would you get the number down?
Yeah.
At this point,
I mean drastic fucking magic.
Do you know they got to put something in the fucking water to just sterilize
people.
Yeah.
And just act like it was a mistake.
Just having Sonta do it.
You can't fucking sue them.
It's illegal.
Right.
Okay.
Well,
whatever the fuck it is,
whatever Obama signed the great liberal fucking president that he was signed
that fucking thing that said,
uh,
you know,
they didn't have to say that their food was genetically altered.
Yeah.
What a patriot.
Huh?
I'll at least fucking Consta or all the same.
Go,
go,
go do your fucking speeches for 500 grand a whack.
Go do that.
Go give your kid a fucking zillion weddings.
You don't give a shit.
Right.
Um,
so it was city,
yea or nay.
What do you say,
yea or Nay?
What do you say?
I say,
go ahead and fucking do it.
He said,
that's what you should do.
You know,
it'd be great about a solar city then we don't need the people's fucking oil in
the Middle East.
And then they gradually just go bankrupt.
You know,
there's no money flying around there.
Then they don't have any money for a fucking nuclear warhead.
And then everybody just relax.
They go back to doing their shit.
We go back to doing our shit.
The reality is,
is in both parts of the world,
most people are just minding their own fucking business.
It's the counts up at the top that hang out with Hillary at the Bilderberg
meetings,
that they're the ones that just can't stand the fact that this fucking people
live in somewhere and they're not making any money off of him.
Oh,
Jesus.
Who had to wait over a third of a chorus,
lightened his fucking say and things.
He's not reading things.
People he spa,
but he's saying,
thanks.
Let's go over to sports.
Oh,
this is a typical fucking sports story now.
Rape survivor finally faces Nebraska's Riley.
Dude,
what the,
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to get away from this shit.
This belongs on the fucking sports page.
It's like they have a rape section.
Do they?
Is that right up to the,
uh,
the Metro region.
All right.
[inaudible] where is the sports?
John Jones says,
hatred for Daniel.
Cormier is fading.
No date is set.
Photogra woods return.
He's got to win another one.
He's got to win one more.
Uh,
after four decade.
Weight manager,
great for grateful for a job.
This is what it's like.
This ranking Mbas.
Worst number one draft picks since 1989.
Of course,
they got Greg Oden there
though.
What they should just show is everybody,
the Portland Trailblazers drafted over the last 30 fucking years.
Oh Shit.
But dig in.
Oh Man,
I think I'll stay on this website.
I wasn't gonna stay up all of [inaudible] bone bone chicken coupon per tank
toto,
but they pop up dead to Bottega.
But Denton Denton.
Then skip.
Skip Bayless gives emotional good bite of first taken Steven A.
Smith.
Oh,
thank God he's leaving.
What's he going to get into?
He should go work with Joel Olsteen.
He should open for him
the two headed monster.
Okay,
well,
everything that both of them say is,
is equally not believable.
All right.
The Philadelphia 70 sixers,
they drafted a Guy Andrea barn game,
while he's name,
he's got a fucking woman's name.
This is men's basketball
purpose.
Alison Sacramento
Kings Ford lasted one season in Sacramento before he's dealt to Washington when
they was still called the bullets where we logged two great years.
That was about it.
Oh,
I,
you know,
if injuries,
injuries,
Dad,
I don't give a fuck about injuries.
It's when you're healthy and you're still suck.
Joe Smith,
is that a fucking alias?
The funny thing about Smith's is his career lasted a long time.
All right.
I don't know any of these people.
Are Michael all a wall?
Wonka donkey.
Kwame Brown.
Greg Oden.
I like Greg.
His how he know he was an old soul.
He looked like Bill Russell does now,
except he's Grecian formula and he came into the league.
He didn't,
we wanted to earn his fucking money.
Anthony Bennett,
number one,
the Cleveland Cavaliers and this is what to be something.
You know what's Great Keith Cavalier fans is now you can fucking laugh about it.
Right?
Did I talk about you guys yet?
No,
cause I talked to before the fucking game.
Congratulations.
I cannot fucking believe how happy I was when the Cavaliers won.
We were working in,
in uh,
Baltimore,
and I watched,
watched like the first quarter.
Then I went on stage when I got off.
Thank God it was the NBA,
there was still like fucking three quarters left.
No,
there was like five minutes left,
10 minutes left.
I can't fucking remember.
I watched most of the fourth quarter.
Right.
Which would be like 10 minutes and I can't remember what the fuck happened.
That guy hit the three.
Joe Barry Carroll hit that fucking three.
And I live,
he was watching,
watching,
watching and thinking,
you know,
I knew I want to Cleveland,
but when he fucking hit that thing,
dude,
I just stood up.
Just so I remember it was almost like when I'm a Bruins,
won the Stanley Cup and all of a sudden there was just like five minutes left
and they were controlling the play and you just could feel it.
I just stood up and I yelled at gonna do it.
They're gonna do it.
And four,
she's going,
don't chicks him.
I'm like,
I am.
I own fucking avenue control over this shit.
And,
uh,
then when the guy who punches everybody in the balls who you can't stand,
but you would love if he was on your team.
Yeah.
Uh,
he fought when he filed Lebron,
I thought the Brian landed on his wrist.
I thought he broke his shooting hand.
I was like,
oh my God did down by there up by three.
He's going to miss them both.
He's going to be out of the fucking game and then the honor,
honor roll students going to come down and hit a fucking three do one is little
skippy fucking dances,
you know?
Um,
that makes you want to give them a leg sweep,
right?
They're going to tie it up,
going to the overtime and they're going to fucking,
and they're going to lose it.
He misses the first one and I knew he was going to hit the next one.
He seemed all right.
Now go,
he's going to fucking hit it.
Bam.
He hits it.
That was great.
I got to tell you a little bit too much crying for me though.
I didn't mind Lebron crying,
but I don't know what the fuck is that guy in that suit on your bench?
I didn't see much of a,
you know,
cause you know Lebron coaches the fucking,
what's his name?
Lou.
I mean that guy,
that guy was like balling.
I can understand the Bronx.
It was just a lot of crying.
I was trying to picture pat.
We're like the Lakers winning it.
Magic Johnson crying like that and then fucking Lebron now mean that Lebron
fucking pat,
Pat Riley also crying like that,
bent over and like his hair comes down.
You know,
cause the Mousse isn't holding it anymore.
it's a different time.
This is what happens when you put Doctor Phil on for fucking 20 years.
You know,
he just keep back in guys into the can open up,
open up,
open up while lady say goes,
is that what you wanted to see?
Bunch of people falling to their knees and you know,
started it.
Chris Bosh started it.
I actually respected the fact that he did it.
You know,
he just got it.
I lost the fucking championship.
He was sad.
He just fucking cried.
Um,
let me read a little bit of advertising here just a little bit.
Oh,
club,
Debbie going to be happy.
I bet on the warriors,
a club w delivers wind straight to your door.
We send you wine that is personalized to your palate.
By the way,
I had a fucking bet with Rappaport.
I still haven't heard from the man.
Still haven't heard from him.
It's still not as still.
I fucking called the final game.
That warriors game,
you know the spread was seven.
I said give me eight and that was the exact fucking number.
Now what do we do?
Double and nothing.
I said the Cavaliers and seven and you know I have not heard from that man.
So all you fucking Michael Rappaport's,
the real Rappaport,
whatever he's calling himself right now.
Then the Taurus Michael Rappaport,
you let that man know that there's another man on another fucking podcast who
also doesn't know what the fuck he's talking about and he's looking for.
Okay,
cause that's son of a bitch owes me a steak dinner.
All right.
Anyways,
Club Dabi Club.
Debbie,
I can bash desc.
I stole a bunch of gold bars from my last day in office.
Delivers wind straight to your door.
We send you wine that is personalized to your palate tastes through our pallet
quiz.
Our recommendations become even more personalized with every bottle you rate.
So the more you booze,
the more we know about you.
We work with top wine makers and growers from around the world directly to make
all of our own wine are $13 bottles would normally retail for $20.
You choose the type in the quantity of bottles and no membership fee or
cancellation fee and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
We partner with local artists to develop wine labels that are unique works of
art.
That's actually cool.
How'd it get your complimentary wine?
Please visit www.club debbie.com take the pallet quiz and register for an
account.
Uh,
he should have a promo code in an email sent to you by Charles and ox Oxford
road.com.
Apply the Promo Code at checkout.
All right.
I don't know what that means is that sounds like I'm not getting any credit.
Maybe they're sick of me going club Debbie Club.
Debbie,
I used to booze,
now I speak Spanish.
All right.
Bolin branch everybody.
As you set out to improve yourself,
there is one simple thing you could do every day to help you be your best in
every situation and that is getting a good night's sleep.
Boll and branch delivers the rest.
Another fucking Maufe Boll and branch delivers the rest you need wrapped up in
their super comfortable luxury linens and they do it right there.
The first bedding company to be fair trade certified,
which means that your sheets come from the work hap be come from the workup,
happy hands,
not sweatshop hands and beautiful packaging made entirely from recyclable,
recycled,
sustainable materials.
Next,
please mention the,
I've got to mention it.
You can only get these sheets in one place.
That's Boll and branch.com where you know you're paying for quality and not
disbarment store overhead.
You're getting thousand dollars sheets for just a couple of hundred bucks.
Go online to bold the branch,
that's B o l l and branch.com and they'll let you try them.
Risk free for 30 nights.
If you don't love him,
you can send them back.
Russ,
you have nothing to loose and it gets even better.
Go to Boll and branch.com today for 20% off your entire order sheets,
towels,
blankets,
do VA covers everything plus free shipping and all that products come
beautifully packaged and the signature boxes boxes go to boll and branch.com
today.
Oh,
nearly off their twin.
You get 20% off your entire order and use the Promo Code Burr.
It's ball,
B,
O,
l l and branch B r a n c h like cliff.com Promo Code Bar Boll and branch.com
promo code,
Bro.
All right,
two more.
Two more.
Hang in there.
Hang in that track or cash.
Smartphones,
smart homes.
Technology has made everything wicked smart,
but losing your stuff's still makes smart people feel really fucking stupid.
Tracker makes losing things a thing of the past kid.
Hey,
skip up.
Listen to this shit.
Track is a coin side device that locates Ms. Plays,
keys,
wallets,
bags,
computers,
anything in seconds to fucking 12 pack way that go BBB ball.
There it is.
Let's get fucking hammered kid.
Just pair,
track it a fucking smartphone,
attach it to anything and find these precise location with the tap of the
button.
Where's my way,
dude?
Not a problem.
It's right over there.
Let's fucking burn one before we go to work.
Dude.
It's that easy.
Lose your fucking phone.
No problem.
Press to fucking track a button.
Are you catching on yet?
You fucking stick it on shit that you lose and when you lose it,
you hit a fucking button with over 1.5 million devices.
Track is has the largest crowd gps network in the world,
so you lost fucking items.
Show up on a map.
Even if it's fucking miles away,
kid.
How fucked up is that?
You want another bud light by it?
Never lose anything again with tracker.
Listen to this show.
Get a special discount.
A 30% off your entire fucking order.
Go to the spelled t h.
G what do you fucking still put his something
temptation t h e track at.com and enter the Promo Code Berbee you are the
hardest thing.
Your level you have to find is they're fucking website.
Go to track i.com right now and enter the Promo Code [inaudible] for 30% off
your entire fucking order.
Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Cobra.
You fucking cock suckers.
All right.
Last but not least,
zip.
Are you hiring?
Okay.
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the job sites and now you can,
uh,
with zip
rep quota dot cup.
Sorry.
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites including social media networks like
Facebook,
Twitter,
and we're all with one single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch all your qualified candidates roll into zip
recruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails.
Call to your calls,
to your office or any of that other bullshit quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire them.
Hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by over 800,000 businesses.
And right now,
listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/bird that's
ziprecruiter.com/ [inaudible] one more time it goat.
It's free.
Go to zip
recruiter.com/bar.
All right,
there we go.
I think that's the podcast here.
That's the podcast.
I hope you fucking enjoy that.
Um,
the weekend's coming up every body up a bar.
Get into baseball wisdom wimbleton coming up.
I'll use sports fans out there.
You know what I mean?
When you're not reading about a rape case,
you know when you want to watch a game,
you know when you're not reminded that people are dying of cancer or you know,
whatever fucking other,
all other miserable motherfucking thing.
They just got to bring up with sports all the God damn time.
Now you know what it is?
Is everybody's watching sports now.
Nobody's watching the news.
So now they got to try to jam all the news.
They got to jam the news of fucking telethon.
You know,
just any fucking goddamn thing going on.
there's an outbreak of the mumps and next thing you know they're going to parade
a bunch of kids out with swollen faces.
How about a moment of silence?
You know,
everybody puff out their cheeks in silence.
I watch sports to get away from that shit.
Okay?
I fucking hate people.
There are a bunch of,
yeah,
I know I can.
I hate groups.
I don't,
I don't mind individuals.
Okay?
With an individual.
I can see the fucking light,
but I don't need to be reminded.
Okay?
I'm trying to get away from that fucking shit and uh,
I,
I don't know where to go.
If you're going to take sports from me,
I don't know what to tell you,
but you know what?
That's a topic for another fucking podcast.
All right?
Have a great weekend you cunts.
Good luck to you and all your future fucking decision making and a,
and that's it.
It does me a little bit of music here and then you'll enjoy,
hopefully you'll enjoy some,
a throwback fucking quips from a podcast
from another time.
Simpler.
The body likes soft down in the sun.
I tried to sue the thought,
nothing to do with straps,
words in the dirt and watch the water rolls down.
Phantom just wasn't like Dan sex sled jump and down on the red.
Zack,
my candy land out the down to syrup while I watched a lot of rolled down.
But sit down and map.
So see my mouth was,
hey,
what's going on far
the
Monday morning podcast.
Before I get started with the podcast,
I want to thank all of you who watched me last night on the bow.
Was it the guys' choice awards on Spike?
Um,
I dunno what happened.
I did six minutes to stand up.
Evidently they cut it down to two minutes.
Maybe it's because I'm dangerous.
I don't know what,
I probably should have told people to Tivo it.
I Dunno.
I guess some people might've been,
I dunno,
I didn't say I was hosting it.
You know what I mean?
Some people were upset by how,
you know,
like dude,
what the fuck?
You know,
she had to fucking and hour and a half and you all you on for fucking two
minutes.
Well,
guess what?
I didn't direct it.
All right.
I don't edit it.
If I did,
it would have been two hours of me would,
it would have been the,
uh,
Bill Burr Tyler Perry presents,
Bill Burrs,
fucking guys choice awards.
And it would have been two hours of me.
Uh,
you know,
actually,
you know what,
I do a little bit of stand up.
This is how I do it.
A little bit of standout,
um,
get a standing ovation and then Oprah would suddenly appear on like this
motorized couch,
like a sofa,
and she just sort of be brought to the front of the stage.
And as I was putting the mic and the mic stand,
so just be seamless.
Like we wouldn't even have commercials.
And,
uh,
then I would sit down and she would just start interviewing me with like some
sort of,
uh,
you know,
turtleneck sweater on,
and,
uh,
you know,
just ask me how I,
how,
how is it that I became so amazing,
you know?
So picture that now,
what do you think would be worth what the fuck you saw last night or that
horrific image I just brought up?
Um,
anyways,
uh,
this is the Monday morning podcasts.
I do one of these every week and that's a truck driving by.
If he can hear that Jesus Christ,
um,
I do one of these every week,
uh,
Ya Bullshit.
The 25 minutes or so,
and I answer questions that people might have and La Times I ask questions and
then people give me answers.
Like last week I didn't know the difference between effect and effect.
And,
uh,
somebody 70 fucking two paragraphs,
which was annoying.
You know,
I want a definition.
Okay.
My world,
a definition is one sentence to number,
you know,
and then they write the fucking definition.
And then maybe there's a number two and number three,
but I never fucking read those.
So,
uh,
I'll try to abbreviate these.
Uh,
the word app fact within a,
as an asshole is primarily used as a verb in English.
Oh,
okay,
good.
Because I want to make sure I don't fuck it up when I'm speaking Latin later on
today.
Anyways,
it has two main meanings,
which are quotes he related effect may mean to alter the feelings of or to
change the mental state of someone or something may also mean in a percent to
change or affect someone or something in any way.
See,
I still don't know what that means.
This is why I'm a comedian because I,
you know,
I sucked in school.
It may also mean in a broader sense to change or fix someone or something in any
way.
That doesn't even mean anything.
The word eat,
fuck it.
Let's move on to effect.
Maybe if I know what effect is,
if I know the definition of that thing,
that when the word doesn't fit into the definition of that,
I'll know what's fucking effect,
effect and contrast.
When contrast is used primarily as a noun in English as a number of related
meetings.
And you know what,
I just realized I don't give a shit.
And right there people you'll realize why I got an eight 10 combined on my sats.
I don't know what part of the country you're from,
but in my neck of the woods,
a 1600 was a perfect score and I believe you got a good 300 points just for
signing your fucking name.
And I got an eight 10 combined and I'd love to sit there and tell you that I
didn't try.
And then I was like,
man,
it's all bullshit.
Fucking government with these tests,
man.
I wasn't like that.
I tried with all my might and all my concentration.
I actually was doing what he might,
even ones that I did know the answer to which ever dealt with was more than 70%
of the fucking test.
I would try to do the process of elimination and uh,
you know,
you think Jesus Christ,
I could guess it's it.
It was,
it was definitely,
it wasn't even devastating.
None of it was devastating because of my great mindset that I had in high
school,
which was basically,
I don't give a fuck.
That was a,
that's been my mindset for a long time and I'm 40 years old and I'm paying the
price for it.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
this is what's going on in my life.
This,
uh,
this week.
All right?
This is really becoming a code,
codependent thing here.
I keep asking you guys to help.
Remember the back in the day when you guys ask me questions and I answered them
down fucking asking you questions and I have actually have an answer.
Then he got them questions in a couple of weeks.
So why don't I go to that?
That's what I'm going to do then to go to the questions.
Okay,
let's read a couple of here and then I'll get to my fucking questions for you
guys.
And this is going to be a blue collar question.
All right?
So if you're clicking away on a spreadsheet,
you can just tune out and about 10 minutes.
But anyways,
here are the questions.
Hey bill law,
when you go to a baseball game,
do you prefer a night game or a day game?
Well,
considering,
um,
uh,
fucking pasty,
I definitely prefer the,
uh,
I definitely prefer the night games.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
Cause I don't want to get a sunburn.
And then also getting shit faced during the day is really a depressing thing.
Past a certain age,
you know,
you do it at night,
it's no big deal.
You know,
you get shit faced at night,
you come home and you pass out and you wake up and there's about 10 seconds of
what the fuck did I do that for?
Before the phone rings and your day starts and you don't really have time to
contemplate what a fucking loser you are.
But when you get shit faced during the day at a fucking baseball game,
aside from the fact that,
uh,
you know,
the odds of you scaring children are increased by 80%.
When you go to a day game and get hammered.
Um,
yeah.
Then you fucking go home and it's like,
uh,
I dunno,
you get home at like six and you're just drunk.
You know,
maybe a pass out for like till like eight and then you wake up and fucking the
TV's on way too loud.
Somebody screaming about dancing with the stars,
you know,
and then you can't fall asleep again to one in the mornings and then you order a
fucking pizza and it's just a,
it's just vicious circle.
Start thinking things like,
man,
what if I just ran head first into that bookcase?
Maybe I could just knock myself out and I wouldn't have to sit here smelling
like draft beer
with a third degree burns on my forehead.
Yeah.
So they go,
I uh,
I prefer to go to the night games.
Lots of day games.
They always have those fucking stupid giveaways.
First 200 people,
it's backpack day,
you know,
or bad day.
You know,
it's great.
They even got rid of that day because they thought it was two filing and what's
so fucking,
but you know,
if this is what kills me was back in the day when they had a bad day,
you went down there and you've got a full slot,
full size,
full size baseball bat.
A Goddamn Louisville slugger.
You've got a full size fucking batch.
It was ridiculous.
You know,
and all this talk about fucking global warming and uh,
you know,
oil and all that crap.
People trying to come up with solutions,
it always blows my mind that they never talk about that day.
How the amount of fucking trees that they had to chop down to give away like
5,000 bats at every game around,
around the God Damn God damn league.
How many fucking teams when the leave,
when I was a kid,
like 26,
26 times 5,000 let's see,
2,410 it's fucking hundred 25,000 plus I don't another 30.
Oh,
it's like 150,000 fucking bets.
You know,
but don't listen to me.
I got an eight,
10 combined.
I'm like fucking sats.
And I tried to,
Jesus Christ,
I tried.
I was devil,
you know,
and they usually say,
when you give 100%,
you know,
it's one of the great things about giving 100% is that you can't,
you can't feel bad.
Who's bringing me?
Jesus Christ.
This is my home phone.
I'm going to have to blow this off.
Do you know what you know?
You know who's calling me right now and I'm going to blow it off.
I bought a,
I bought a set of,
uh,
you know,
those gymnastic rings.
Do you guys watch,
do you watch the gymnasium?
You ever watched that shit?
How many fucking times is my phone and before it goes to the gut in the shame,
evidently 26.
Um,
you guys ever watch,
uh,
this is my deal,
man.
I'm trying to,
uh,
you know,
turn 40 fucking trying to compensate.
So I'm trying to find new ways to get in shape.
You know,
I mean,
how many times can you go down to the gym and start throwing the weights around
like your Lou Ferrigno,
you know,
plus when you lift weights,
you don't necessarily get in.
You get in like 80 shape in the 80s.
The girls will like,
you know,
trying to dress like Olivia Newton,
John doing aerobics,
you know,
I don't know.
Dress,
I'm like strippers and then all the guys,
everybody,
everybody.
Basically in the 80s,
everybody had a huge upper body and then they had pretzel rod legs cause nobody
did.
Nobody did like snow.
We did squats,
you know,
everybody's Oh fucking chest and back.
Well in and Fi's.
Oh,
so you know,
I dunno,
you lift weights,
you just get off fucking,
you get all puffy.
So I was just sitting there,
uh,
I don't know,
I was flipping through the channels,
right.
I'm not going to lie to you.
Gymnastics came on and it always kind of blows my mind the level of strengths
that those guys have.
And uh,
I was sitting on the floor and I was watching somebody,
they went into a,
I think it's called the pike position.
So I was like,
Shit,
you know,
and I do sit ups.
I bet I could try and do that.
And I can't even explain to you like,
do you ever tried to do something?
And it's like,
not only can you not,
I mean physically,
not only can you not do it that your brain,
it's like you don't even have those muscles.
So when you go to do it,
you actually feel like you're paralyzed because you're sending this message to
you muscle going,
okay,
do this.
And it's not even like your muscles going like,
you know,
I tried but we can't.
There's like no response.
It's like yelling down a hole cause some fucking five year old who fell down in
the middle of a white trash town in Arkansas.
I Dunno,
let's get,
let's get that contract.
So I bought these,
uh,
they're called the lead rings and uh,
you fucking your time to a chin up bar and uh,
you know,
basically your work your way up.
One day you're doing an iron cross right in the middle of your living room as
you're watching the fucking evening news.
So that's what I'm working towards.
Okay.
So I get these goddamn rings.
I'm all excited,
right?
You think I had a kid or something like this is how fucking excited and self
centered I am,
that I get that excited about something material that I bought for myself.
Rather than bringing a new life into the world that I can,
uh,
you know,
try to nurture or whatever it is you do as a parent.
And anyways,
I got these things that for the life of me,
I can't figure out how to fucking,
how to set them up.
They gave you,
they gave me this really bad videotape with these Russian guys on it.
Dcs,
dcs,
that EMEA.
So,
and saw the 19,
the 2005 rings champion he had,
he is doing an inverted fucking whatever,
you know,
but they never showed you how to put the goddamn rope through the fucking ring.
So that's what that phone calls evidently going to be.
Cause I called him up early this morning,
the one 800 number,
and I was like,
yes,
I got the rings.
Oh yes,
they're fantastic.
But your shitty little DVD slash snuff film doesn't explain how to put the
fucking rope to the ring.
You know?
And the guy's like,
go,
okay,
well,
you know,
I don't really have the rings in front of me so I can't really tell you how to
do it.
Uh,
I just like,
yeah,
it's sad on the fucking invoice that if I had a problem I could call this
number.
All right?
They didn't say I'd be talking to you.
You fucking moron.
So basically the guy doesn't even know how to the fucking guy in the one 800,
you know,
what else would I be calling him about?
You know,
Jesus Christ,
but that the invoice that needs,
I got the ranks now,
what else would I be calling him for?
Would I be calling him up to see if he could come over and spot me as I do an
inverted headstands.
So anyways,
he's got to have the head of the company call me or some shit.
I Dunno.
So I blew that off.
I blew it off.
And you guys,
you liked that giving you a little bit of guilt.
All right?
So if anybody knows how to string up fucking gymnastic links for the love of
God,
if you want the cup scouts or something,
if he can somehow tell me how to do that.
So I actually don't fucking break my neck while doing this shit.
It would be greatly appreciated.
All right,
let's move on to the next question.
Um,
oh,
here's one.
Here's one night.
Anyway,
Bill,
I was wondering,
does your grandmother is still drive?
Yes,
she does.
Mike,
you fucking content.
That's an inside joke for people listening to the Opie and Anthony Show.
Next podcast question.
Um,
what will be the moment that makes you decide to stop doing these podcasts?
I am one of the loyal 14 listeners,
as you always say.
I love hearing them,
blah,
blah blah.
So if he keeps them coming every week,
B,
do,
um,
what will be the moment that that makes me stop doing them?
Um,
I dunno.
I'm rubbing my forehead right now with my eyes closed.
Trying to think of an answer.
I don't know
if I actually was,
I probably would've stopped doing them awhile ago,
but I have a need to be liked.
And if I stopped doing them,
it would only take one email from just one person going like,
I can't believe you said stop touring them.
I know.
I really,
I really enjoyed them.
You know,
I've been going through some difficult times lately.
Last summer I was trying to make some lemonade and when I went to put it into
the pitcher,
it's shattered and the glass came up and it hit me in my eye and I haven't been
able to work.
And I then home and every week they look forward to the Monday morning podcast
and as ridiculous as that bucket south,
I actually get stories like that.
So,
uh,
actually I don't get stories like that.
I get more serious ones and uh,
but they're not funny.
So I decided to make up that one about the fucking picture eliminate,
which really wasn't that funny.
Um,
but you know,
you try it,
throw it out there.
Um,
what else do we got here?
I thought I had more fucking questions and that
you own is I fucking take these questions and I copy and paste them and they
just,
somehow they never end up
at three in a row.
Baseball game.
Your grandmother.
Oh,
there's one.
Okay.
So what is your take on this,
this next election?
Uh,
who do you think has a shot at the throne and are you test how much hype it's
getting?
I don't know.
That's how he ends it.
Id K uh,
yeah.
I can't believe how much heights the,
uh,
who's going to be the next president of the United States is getting,
what the fuck was that?
Um,
yeah,
it's always annoying when things that don't deserve to be heights,
like landing on the moon and a,
the next presidential election or getting,
you know,
I wish they would continue focusing on other things that are more important,
like a,
the next American idol.
Um,
who's left in the Big Brother House and,
uh,
I don't know when the next episode of fucking mind [inaudible] I don't know.
No,
I'm not pissed it,
uh,
I gotta be honest with you.
I haven't even been watching it because I get so God damned depressed that they
never really talk about anything.
And no matter what you ask them to be like a,
you know,
hey,
what are you gonna do about the troops in Iraq?
And then we'll just be like,
you know,
the troops in Iraq,
uh,
is an issue that everybody is very concerned about and it's something that
definitely needs to be addressed.
And,
uh,
when the time is right,
we are going to sit down with some people who are very not knowledgeable in that
field and we are going to have an assessment.
Um,
and after doing some sort of research,
we will arrive at a,
uh,
a conclusion that we will be presenting our next question.
And that it just becomes that,
um,
we're,
I think as a shot at the throne.
Well,
I mean,
I spent a lot of time in New York and La,
so obviously I would think that Barack is going to win by a landslide.
But when I go on the road and I get to some of these other states,
like North Carolina and Georgia,
you know,
and you walk down the street and for some reason the music in your head switches
from Jack Johnson suggested good ole boy.
They ever made in the hall.
We told you it was the whole moon and trouble with the lols and the baby was
born.
You think John Mccain's going to win?
Personally,
I don't want a president who can't do the wave.
Okay.
That's
all right.
That's one of the most evil fucking things I have said for those of,
you don't realize John Mccain can't lift his arms past his shoulders because he
was tortured in captivity,
uh,
while fighting for a freedom for myself to do this podcast,
at least that they would,
that's the way they,
they would frame it on Fox News,
you know,
rather than,
uh,
he was pissed at his dad.
He was trying to outdo him and,
uh,
he got a jet and he could have bailed out or flew away,
but he didn't.
And uh,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
what the fuck?
I wouldn't have a guilt people about my podcast.
I'm not doing this podcast,
the freedom.
Um,
anyway,
so what do I think's going to win?
I have no fucking idea.
Uh,
I do like John Mccain.
I like John Mccain because,
uh,
the fucking right wing psychos don't like him.
And A,
I don't consider Bush and Dick Cheney to be Republicans.
I consider them to be psychos who call themselves Republicans.
I don't think Republicans are as bad as Bush and Cheney.
I really don't.
I think they were an oil guy.
And,
uh,
a guy who worked at General Electric,
a Halliburton,
we let the nuts run the fucking asylum and that will pay for it.
So either way,
I don't think he,
the guy's going to be a,
I don't know.
I think we,
I don't know Obama,
I don't even fucking know.
I like Ron Paul.
But I've done this before.
I always vote for that fucking guy and he and nobody else does.
You know,
you should see my voting record.
Let's see.
You want to have my voting record.
Lot of people keep this shit private,
but I don't because I don't give a fuck or right.
In 1988 was the first time I voted for president and I voted for George Bush,
Sr over Michael Dukakis.
And it had nothing to do with him sticking his head out of that tank,
squinting looking like some sort of a market.
Um,
I just voted that way because that's the way everyone else around me was voting.
And I was fucking 20 years old now,
right?
1992 I voted for Ross Perot
because,
uh,
I dunno,
he actually seemed to be fucking answering questions,
you know,
and the other two weren't,
Bill Clinton just kept smiling.
Oh,
playing a saxophone,
you know,
trying to be the cool guy.
His campaign,
it fucking posters could just send him leaning against the wall with his thumbs
in his pocket,
looking down the hall with one foot on the floor and the other foot up against
the wall.
You know,
that that bug and that was his fucking pot,
you know,
a puts on weight like a bitch too.
I never liked his mother.
And hips.
Um,
and then in 1996,
a Ross Perot came back.
I wasn't feeling him.
And,
um,
Bob Dole seem like that grumpy guy next door,
who calls the cops when you had a keg party?
So I went with Bill Clinton and a in 2000,
uh,
I didn't like Bush and I didn't like Al Gore.
I didn't like either one of them.
So I went with fucking Ralph Nader
and,
uh,
what the fuck does that lead us?
Please let us to the last one.
I remember who I voted the last time.
I didn't vote for fucking John Kerry and I didn't vote for John Kerry.
You know what killed his campaign for me was when he passed that he was
questioning George Bush for,
uh,
you know,
during Vietnam War,
spending the war in the stock room at a cvs before going home later on that
afternoon.
So he was trying to,
you know,
hype up his military career.
He got behind the podium and he went Saturday carry boarding for duty.
And it was one of the coneys things I've ever seen.
And he delivered the line just,
Oh,
just in a horrible way,
you know,
worse than Mark Wall Walberg in the happening.
I don't know if anybody says anybody seen that fucking movie.
It's so bad.
It's,
it almost comes back around to being good again.
If movies weren't fucking $12 or whatever the fuck they are now,
you know,
I dunno,
just dope.
The moral of the movie that I got is a,
you know,
and this is a spoiler alert.
Spoiler alert.
Can't even say it.
Just fucking plug up.
You've got damn years here.
All right.
I'm going to talk about it for 15 seconds and then you can turn the sound back
up.
All right.
The moral of the happening was basically,
it doesn't make a difference if you're a scientist or if you're some dumb jock.
Nobody knows what the fuck is going on,
but we better love each one,
each other,
better love each other or else the tree.
Cause if we don't the,
uh,
the fucking trees will kill us.
You know what?
I realized my fucking stutterer and through all of that was worse than the
goddamn movie.
All right.
I hope you brought the sound back up.
Okay,
here we go.
We're going to end this podcast with uh,
um,
oh,
bad car stories.
Okay.
And I,
before I go,
I want to thank everybody for coming out to the punchline in Atlanta last week.
I had a great time.
Um,
and uh,
I want to thank that woman who when I was ranting about adopting a dog,
decided to stand up like she was in a coal miner's daughter and a read me the
riot act about fucking great Danes or whatever the hell she was talking about.
But anyways,
thanks for everybody came out there and I'm going to be at the Improv in
Pittsburgh,
uh,
July 10th through the,
through the 13th.
And I will be going to the pirates game and I will be going to a day game
possibly,
which means they'll probably be given away a,
it's fanny pack day.
It's fucking three rivers stadium or whatever you call that new one that shows
that piss yellow bridge in the background.
Every time the other team hits a home run.
Okay,
let's get to a lift.
Get the fucked up car stories here.
Uh,
I,
when I'm serious about those rings,
by the way,
I wasn't kidding.
If anybody knows how to string those things up,
please for the love of God,
let me know.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
just to get people a backstory,
if you knew that my podcast,
I had a dent in my car for three months,
I finally got the fucking thing fixed.
Five days later I took it to a,
I had it valid and I came downstairs and fucking things dented and the exact
same God damn spot.
And uh,
I learned about the expression to be beside oneself.
Alright?
So anyways,
people wanted to tell me that fucking awful car stories,
a lot of anger in these.
So if you're not into a dirty words,
uh,
you might want to block here a block your ears.
Um,
okay.
Uh,
car stories.
Bill,
I liked your podcast and I can relate to the dense story.
Some very old cunt.
I'm very old con as opposed to a,
a,
you know,
middle aged conch or just an old con,
some very old con.
What constitutes a very old con.
I'm going to say,
uh,
older than 78 and has been smoking camel and filters since the 30s.
Um,
some very old content and my car after I had just fixed,
it was running like gold.
It happened a week before Christmas and the old blind bitch,
her name was Emma cunty thing.
Ha Conti.
Things happen.
I never heard that word.
Cunty until I listened to you.
Okay,
well maybe someday I'll teach you how to finish a fucking story.
I guess you just hit it.
It was running like gold.
Can you just abbreviating heaven week for Christmas,
the old blind bitch,
her name was Emma Irma.
All right.
You know,
I'm always fascinated with old people's names like Irma.
You know what I mean?
You hear the name Irma,
you just know it's somebody fucking old,
you know,
or Gladys.
And the weird thing is,
is you know that when they were being born,
like those weren't the new hip names.
Like,
you know,
people name their kids like Dakota,
Someday Dakota,
like later on at the end of this century,
Dakota,
there's an old guy named Dakota.
Um,
oh look,
there's a baby and is his old lady named fucking apple.
Like that name is going to,
that's going to be like a Ebenezer.
That's what happens.
That's what happens,
man.
You can look it up.
All right,
let's get on with these fucking things.
All right.
A yellow bill.
What's going on?
What's going on,
dude?
I have a lancer evolution.
I don't know what that is.
I had a dent in it from getting groceries at Super Walmart.
As much as I hate that fucking evil company,
they had the cheapest.
Well do,
that's yeah,
that's how it works.
If it fucking huge and they've dropped the prices and they put the mom and pops
out of business because idiots like you go to them rather than sticking it out
with the mom and pop and letting the billionaire with his 9 million square feet
go out of fucking business.
So as much as you hate,
Yay.
Yeah,
helping them fucking continue that their domination.
And then he writes whatever.
Almost like he knew I was going to rant about that anyways,
uh,
while I was in there,
I got hit in the front of my car and it dented the shit out of the front bumper
and busted a headlight.
Of course,
I snapped and I went back into the store screaming about this and demanded to
see the parking lot cameras.
I like that.
That's a strong move.
Of course,
that week,
the two far side cameras were not working and I never found out who did it.
Three months later,
after driving around,
constantly looking like a total fucked up loser,
I got it fixed.
Okay.
Three months later you get your car fixed and what happened that night I was
driving and Cleveland,
Ohio.
I live in Medina parentheses,
shit hole and I come out and I hit a massive pothole and blew out my tire,
crack my bumper and wheel well.
I called the city and they just,
and they said that they just passed the bill saying that they were no longer
responsible for damage caused by potholes.
Oh my God.
He writes the rage I had at that point,
I just wanted to kill as many innocent people as possible
after having,
getting my car fixed twice.
You know what,
how does that work within government?
Does anybody notice know how that works?
How do they,
how do they pass a bill that they're not responsible?
You know what I mean?
Like if they ever put that on a bill,
no one,
no regular person,
whatever,
both to have that past.
I wish I could fucking do no longer responsible for getting drunk and putting my
hands on your person.
All right,
here's the last one.
I'm going to wrap up this podcast.
I like this one because all the other ones people have been telling me have been
like a,
you know,
they didn't do anything and uh,
they weren't at fault.
Like,
uh,
like this guy,
I've been without my car for over two weeks now.
First I had to take it to the shop because they had an intake problem.
Uh,
I always think they make that shit up cause I know you don't,
you don't have no idea what it is.
What's like wasn't,
you know,
it was probably my car.
Oh,
you got an intake problem.
Uh,
you've got to post it aspirator too.
They just pick that obscure Shit,
you know?
But anyways,
I was,
it was in the shop like five days and then those five days it felt like I was 16
again.
You know,
before you get your license and you bumming rides off,
everybody just kept thinking,
man,
I gotta get my fucking car.
He's failing all pathetic and shit.
Well,
I got it out and I drove it home with a big stupid grin on my face.
I might have ran an errand or two,
I don't know.
All I know is I took it home,
sat down at a bear,
and I put on the Astros game.
I was in a freaking great move.
It sounds like it got them beer commercial.
This is great,
right?
This guy's life's going awesome.
And what?
Then what happens?
All of a sudden his girlfriend said,
I need to go to the store.
And that annoying tone of hers.
So like a dumb ass.
I let her go.
I get a call from her 15 minutes later and she's calling me from the side of the
road by an ambulance.
She had gotten a wreck.
I love southern people.
She got no wreck,
not just direct.
She fucking totaled the front passenger side of the car.
What makes it worse is that it was her fucking fault.
God Damn it.
I was pissed.
I was honestly going to ask her if the car was okay first,
but I knew that would cause a huge,
huge argument when she got home.
Yeah.
My God,
isn't that the worst?
And you know,
she was just crying her fucking eyes out.
Wasn't she just them just to make you feel like a bully.
If you actually went,
you stupid bitch.
I just got that fucking thing fixed.
I helped you went through the windshield.
You know he did it actually justified in saying that,
but you can't.
So anyways,
those are three,
three great stories with a person with the car was the victim.
And then you get to this last one.
I liked this last one.
Um,
I've had my 99 BMW three 25 I just got some work done on the engine and it runs
like new last month on a Thursday,
a little tipsy,
which means he was shit faced.
I got into my car,
angry at this girl I had been talking to.
Okay.
Did she have bruises on her wrist?
Um,
who's angry?
This girly,
but talking to he backs up furiously in this parking garage,
smack the larger than life pickup truck,
which crushes his entire passenger's side tail light.
It puts a large dent right underneath it.
No one's around.
I leave a note on the car to give me a call if they're pissed.
Not much damage to the huge dodge ram,
which seems to,
we've been parked in the middle of the aisle.
Um,
I don't want to be a Dick,
but,
uh,
that truck wasn't moving.
And you said it was larger than life.
And you also mentioned that you were a little tipsy and you are angry at this
girl.
This is a horrible way to tell this story if you wanted some sort of empathy,
but you know what?
The fact that you brought the broad into the story.
I actually actually feel bad for you.
Why are we a little tipsy?
Huh?
Were you buying her drinks all night?
You know,
I want to hear the rest of this story.
You got to,
you got to email me as to why you were mad at this girl from,
cause I have to know the backstory to me to actually feel bad that you slammed
your BMW into a Goddamn Dodge Ram Jag.
You know what?
It sucks.
I've been there.
I can put my truck into a god damn ditch one time drunk,
pissed off at somebody.
But anyways,
um,
thanks for all the questions.
Thanks for,
uh,
all the,
all the stories about your cars.
Uh,
please come and see me at the Improv in Pittsburgh on next month and uh,
July 10th through the 13th and go to [inaudible] dot com for all the dates and a
one special side note.
I'm actually just found out right before I did this podcast that,
uh,
George Carlin had passed away last night,
ran out here in Santa Monica.
Um,
and I didn't really feel like talking about it to be honest with you,
cause there's two,
uh,
two fucking depressing.
Um,
all I can say about the guys,
he's just,
you know,
he's unbelievable.
And,
uh,
I don't,
I don't really want to talk,
just,
you know,
the guy,
the guy got fired in 2001.
I was always like a big thing for me.
The fact that the guy was in his sixties and he could still say shit that
actually got him fired in Las Vegas.
And,
uh,
you know what I mean?
Most people run out of steam by the time they fucking my age.
And that guy,
you know,
25 years later,
it's still,
we're still freaking people out.
But,
uh,
I mean,
I don't need to tell you guys this,
but just without a doubt,
without a doubt,
easily top three of all time,
I put them right there,
prowler,
prior Carlin and uh,
and Lenny Bruce.
And,
uh,
it's fucking brutal.
Fucking brutal.
What an awful way I see these by didn't bring it up.
I just want to bring out and try to give you guys laughs on the shift rather
than talk about,
but he was one of the,
one of the two reasons I got into this shit where him and Richard Pryor and I
used to do my paper route
doing his bits,
delivering papers,
pretending I was him onstage in front of my kids.
I went to school with,
um,
that's how much I love to stuff.
That's how much the guy meant to me.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
rest in peace and a,
I know he didn't believe in an afterlife.
So,
uh,
I dunno.
Enjoy your time in the ground George and thanks for all the laughs.
Alright everybody,
thanks for listening to the podcasts and not please keep the questions coming
and if anybody knows how the fuck I'm supposed to hang up these Goddamn rinks,
uh,
please let me know and
Yah,
that's it.
Everybody have a good week.
[inaudible]
suck a lot to say on the side of
Samsung.
The present
to change and look like this spans
saw come out in the water,
rolls down
the line.
[inaudible] on dawn.
Day on Don,
Don,
who bought the lot of own town.
Sam dug down,
down,
down.
Watch Vermont alone.
Plus the water rolls down.
Watched a lot of row and down.
Watch the water roll down.
No.